alors c'était une télévision locale
[Musique]
l'actrice y allait souvent les lois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après trois ou quatre ans d'existence
tu laisses où j'avais trouvé sa vitesse
de croisière et diffusion des magazines
et des films avaient lieu régulièrement
dans tous les petits villages du canton
de montbenoît l'équipe de bénévoles
étaient parfaitement rodée et le
matériel vidéo évolué ainsi en 1980 plus
de temps en france 3 me lançant t'es les
sujets avaient enfin trouvé la couleur
avec une belle camaraderie cube un tube
vers un cube bleu attoub rouge
bonjour les convergences et un boom que
l'on retrouve dans le clip de la vache
qui a égayé quelques festival d'art
vidéo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais les bénévoles ont bien d'autres
souvenirs qu'elle sera même ordre à la
cuisine de l'abbaye de montbenoît tenir
la caméra filme et passion on vous
prenez plaisir à partir dans les deux
films sortis des ordis aubry qu'est-ce
qui nous a jamais failli ils savent
comment je me sens
des parties puissent accorder comme ça
c'est parti fabriquer de génériques
comme ça la fabrique que bonds a tracé
souvent là tous les bénévoles pourront
ici mais ça nous prend une journée ou
deux journées chacun amène ses coûts sa
facture et son tracteur et on tourne
voilà et ça donne parfois des choses
yamar en mettant plus près encore
mais encore
non
bon alors qu'est ce qu'on pourrait le
penser ce soir de toute façon tout est
bien
[Musique]
comme l'habit ne fait pas lemoine
génériques ne faut pas la télé nos
programmes diverses et variées collet
naturellement souvent à la réalité
l'économie du canton reposant sur les
pages on se retrouvait tous les ans on
connaissait agricole gino des experts
ces deux classes et les animaux dans
chaque section
selon leur leurs convictions et selon
malgré tout à ce type de rechercher dans
le race montbéliarde
est-ce que vous fréquentez puce qui
commit sa période électorale ou très
bonne question
très bonne question parce que depuis que
je suis élu au conseil général depuis le
début de la plus forte raison j'ai
pratiquement assisté à tous les comices
bien qu'il n'y ait pas d'échéances
électorales
un député bérubé et
malheureusement il y à une fois passé
l'aspect concours de beauté les
rencontres mondaines
on abordait les vrais problèmes comme
l'application brutale des quotas
laitiers
celle autrefois âgées non parce que là
j'ai pas olivia millions d'amis ont
chacun totalisé pacte inégalités la
reconnaissance par ce coup là je refais
ballon arrivait plus rien mais c'est
alors je paye 3 millions et demi la
petite chose que j'ai dépassé je traite
9h il pour le bien de la chanson
d'exemples pris que sept ans ça va plus
modeste de sa frappe
safran pour les voix de toutes façons je
traite le plus six vaches mais moins 9 h
he alors pendant fin gérer des déchets
qu'on a toujours proposé prodige et en
même temps la facilité cette production
et ça va en faire profiter tout le monde
il ya eu un non sens mais de dire à des
gens tout proche produisez plus
puis tout d'un coup sans préavis ou
presque lardy bombe d'armes et innovante
de ce que produisent y est on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez allez mettez trop grand quand même
de ces quotas oui bien sûr j'étais au
courant et ils courent tous très bien
voilà cinq six ans et je pourrais dire
mais attention même parce qu'un projet
petit papa temps si c'est parce que mais
on va se dire on peut peut-être pas
existé sa pige entraves qui savaient
peut-être rien mais alors que nous
devions aller un peu loin mais manque de
pot ça mais tac rock vient télé et télé
vous l'avez compris il ya les grandes
télés l'équipe et avec annie morillon on
est allé voir que vous êtes allé voir
tout seul d'ailleurs et les petites
télés qu'on appelle télé broue voilà je
me suis demandé de lire c'était normal
que ça vienne juste après les rires la
séquence un peu ringard mais je vais
parce que c'est le premier sujet comme
ça ça va dans l'injustice et peut-être
un gars tu verras comme c'est ça je sais
pas vous savez ce que c'est qu'une télé
- vous avez bien j'espère donc l'été
lebron c'est des petites télés rural il
y en a 8 9 10 en france et puis comme l
ont pas de moyens de diffuser parce
qu'on leur attache pas une grande
importance
eh bien il tourne des sujets comme ça
tous les jours une petite équipe de
trois on est allé voir et puis ils vont
les porter avec leur voiture après ma
télé l'écran et puis vous le portez dans
le bistrot la mairie alors le dit matt
s'intéresse pas à eux mais ils font
sacrée soirée tous ensemble et vous
allez voir ce que ça donne c'est lé soja
c'est la puissance physique sous génois
nous vous invitons à découvrir le tour
de france 1985
l'élection du nouveau maire de juillet
le bal masqué à art sous cicon le jubilé
a bus ni les vendanges dans les vignes
en côte d'or et la fête de la musique a
contaminé et le poitou recoins comment
ça se passait très bien enfin il vous
des verts qui nous à la dan hôtel terne
nous avions trois faux qu'il avait un
poulet toutes mes années et pour la
plaph au jeu ne m'avait pas les
traqueurs comme ça le début vous
compreniez quand on s'est marié en 1923
et si on faisait de les points avec les
voitures à échelle
puis après une halte des plateformes
comme maintenant pierre ponnelle
détracteurs si on avait une caennaise on
avait une rampe ne s'était pas des gens
modernes d'aujourd'hui et puis le soir
quand vous voyez le nouvel ace alexis
rhône et maintenir une pluie le long des
falaises affirmé qu'il faisait beau ça
fait comme pour faire les voitures écolo
dit on les habille et des jours après
les protéger oui on en met des 17 autres
étaient encore devant et tous les temps
est gris gay pour faire partir et nous
on a prétendu du shass nous donc
commencer les points habituellement par
là à la fin juillet
fin juillet par an auparavant nous mais
maintenant les commandes bien plutôt
comme qu'ils mettent des engrais alors
il englobe les vieilles terres de frein
bien plus de bonheur
vous comprenez voilà que vous finissiez
les points quand on a aucune du ciel et
wade peut monter le ton monte oh moi
j'ai vu qu'on guettait d'amis pendant
notre guèye en à rester sous la nef du
soin du foie ou du regain du point où
c'était pas bien comment ça allait mais
maintenant cette difficile il ne tend
pas à tuer et voilà on n'était pas
toujours bien gai vous savez il faut pas
quoi autrefois enfin nettement non plus
après nos agréable mission d'ethnologie
d'urgence et de souvenir du bon vieux
temps on retournait a le devoir de
télémiroir l'actualité étant
régulièrement ponctuées de fête locale
[Musique]
à
oh
et
[Musique]
alors j'aurai savoir comment vous faites
pour choisir les sujets que vous aller
filmer à télé sauget ben on choisit
souvent les gens c'est à dire les sujets
qui sont susceptibles de plaire aux gens
nous disent on comprend on prend comme
sujet surtout ceux qui ont trait au
village ce que les gens du village
ceux qui veulent voir us s est lui-même
on a déjà essayé au début de la création
de projets de 2 passes et des reportages
vidéo qu'on avait fait dans les villages
voisins et les gens regarder mais au
bout d'un certain moment vous voyez qui
n'était plus guère intéressés eux s'ils
veulent voir c'est leur tête
or c'est ce qu'on essaie de faire
aujourd'hui par par le reportage sur la
fête de 9
on essayait déjà déjà y être surtout de
prendre les têtes des gens pour que il
se voit vous allez dire que je ne peux
pas bon bien monsieur vous êtes
producteur à fr3 nationale et vous êtes
venus aujourd'hui pour faire une
émission sur arte les sauget l'idée
était de montrer que ça bouge dans le
milieu rural en matière de vidéo et de
choisir un exemple pour essayer d'aller
plus loin avec cet exemple là alors nous
avons choisi télé sauget il est
incontestable que à télé sauget et dans
les télés rural en général
il n'y a pas les mêmes impératifs de
durée l'antenne que l'on peut avoir dans
la télévision
donc ils prennent le temps ils ont le
temps ils le prennent 7 à poigne points
deuxième point c'est un autre regard une
autre approche des problèmes d'actualité
fait par des gens qui sont dans leur
propre milieu
il en ressort dans les reportages
quelque chose de plus direct le plus
spontané pas forcément de plus vrai mais
de différent au moins c'est ça qui m'a
intéressé c'est la différence entre ce
que l'on fait nous d'habitude
est ce que peut faire une télévision
comme telle et sauget
allez
pourquoi vous êtes tous là pour dégager
un peu de notre temps et puis parce que
des gens par mois sur l'autre et puis
dégager la cheminée parce que si on
revient encore eu d'annoncé en revient
encore une vingtaine de centimètres
c'est pourquoi payer leurs filets
la chance qu'on a hâte elisso j'ai c'est
que dans chaque village du canton ancré
15 villages il ya un ou deux bénévoles
qui sont dus qui sont du coin et
instituteurs docteur commerçants
artisans et qui vivent dans le village
toute l'année sont vraiment en prise
directe avec ce qui si ce qui s'y dit
vous allez chercher votre enfant l'école
bon les gens discutent entre eux le
paysan même sens les à la cool et
toujours comme ça des informations qui
circulent bon et puis nos pneus
la majorité des informations de revient
par le bénévolat les gens comprendraient
pas qu'on n'habite pas les mêmes raisons
que que on n'est pas les mêmes
préoccupations que l'on vit on vit à
l'intérieur du soja est tout ce qu'ils
vivent eux ça ne nous est pas étranger
c'est vraiment une
une télé de proximité au vrai sens du
terme un des rôles importants des
animateurs bénévoles était de préparer
des soirées
c'est à dire faire de la publicité aller
chercher le matériel donne village
précédent chauffer la salle accueillir
les spectateurs et assurer la projection
dans la salle certains spectateurs
s'ils savaient qu'ils gardent épuise
amis les voisins passer l'information
comme quoi ils avaient été filmés et 6
avril
ces grosses qu'il souhaitait world vous
avez quelques histoires difficiles des
prisons futures mamans est donc devenu
le film est rédigée par ubi bene
quelques années vous bien tu m'as pris
juste un jeu wii sujet ce soir
projection un peu exceptionnelle car
c'est un reportage sur le québec réalisé
quelques mois auparavant par cinq
bénévoles de télécharger voyage d'étude
[Musique]